to the section 30 order it's a legal
clause essentially which gives the power
from westminster to the scottish
parliament to be able to carry out that
referendum boris johnson doesn't want to
give it to nicolas sturgeon nor does
westminster and i think
without that there's much frustration uh
from uh for nicolas sturgeon and the snp
so it may be the case that we hear from
the first minister today look we're
going to do this without you uh we are
going to hold maybe some sort of
consultative referendum some poll where
essentially they may well ask the
scottish people not a yes or no answer
like it was in 2014. moray do you think
the scottish government should start
negotiations with westminster over the
future of independence for scotland so
i think today we're putting aside the
sort of falls and against and the either
side arguments over the referendum it's
a it's a logistical one over how
i think the first minister now is is
about to speak so we'll cross over to
the parliament and see what she's got to
say
would improve the lives of those who
live here and so it has proved
there were and still are honorable
differences about the ultimate
destination of scotland's
self-government journey
but all who campaigned to establish this
place were united in and by this
fundamental principle the democratic
rights of the people of scotland are
paramount
that principle of self-determination was
encapsulated
by these words in the scottish
constitutional conventions claim of
right
the sovereign rights of the scottish
people to determine the form of
government best suited to their needs
when the late cannon kenyan right who
led the convention addressed
westminster's refusal to accept the
democratic demand for a scottish
parliament with this question
what if that other voice we all know so
well responds by saying
we say no and we are the state
his answer
well we say yes and we are the people
were simple but powerful and it is as
relevant now as it was
then presenting officer last may the
people of scotland said yes to an
independence referendum by electing a
clear majority of msps committed to that
outcome
the democratic decision was clear
two weeks ago the scottish government
started the process of implementing that
decision with the first in the building
a new scotland series of papers
that paper presented compelling evidence
of the stronger economic and social
performance
relative to the uk of a range of
independent countries across europe that
are comparable to scotland
that should be both a lesson and an
inspiration to us
scotland over generations has paid a
price for not being independent
westminster governments we don't vote
for imposing policies we don't support
too often holding us back from
fulfilling our potential
that reality has really been starker
than it is now
the conservatives have just
six mps in scotland barely 10
of scottish representation and yet they
have ripped us out of the eu against our
will
they have created the worst cost of
living crisis in the g7 and saddle does
with the second lowest growth in the g20
they are intent on stocking industrial
strife demonizing workers and provoking
a trade war
businesses and public services are
struggling for staff because freedom of
movement has been ended our young people
have been robbed of opportunity
presiding officer the scottish
government will do everything in our
power to mitigate the damage but that is
not enough our country deserves better
and yet this parliament looked to for
leadership by so many across scotland
does not have the power to tackle the
root causes of the financial misery
being inflicted on millions we lack the
full range of levers to shape our
economy and grow our country's wealth we
are powerless to stop our budget being
cut
we can't block the tory's new anti-trade
union laws or stop them tearing up human
rights protections
we're not able to restore freedom of
movement
and while we invest billions
billions in measures to help with the
cost of living
tens of thousands of children can be
pushed deeper into poverty at the
nearest stroke of the chancellor's pen
preceding officer
it does not have to be this way
independence is about equipping
ourselves to navigate the future guided
by our own values aspirations and
interests it is about helping us fulfill
our potential here at home and play our
part in building a better world
and that does take more than a changing
of the guard at westminster
i
fervently hope that the tories lose the
next election they thoroughly deserve to
but on the big policy issues of our time
from europe to migration to human rights
and fairness for workers
labour is more a pale imitation than a
genuine alternative
labour won't take scotland back into the
european union or even the single market
and neither will the liberal democrats
they won't restore freedom of movement
for our young people they won't
prioritize tackling child poverty over
investment in nuclear weapons
presiding officer first minister first
minister sorry could i just have a
moment i have asked that there are no
interruptions during the first minister
statement i would be grateful if we
could have some silence thank you for
spelling officer
independent won't always be easy it
isn't for any country but independence
will give us the opportunity to chart
our own course to build a wealthier
greener fairer nation to be outward
looking and internationalist to lift our
eyes and learn from the best presenting
officer now is the time at this critical
moment in history to debate and decide
the future of our country now is the
time to get scotland on the right path
the path chosen by those who live here
now is the time for independence
presenting officer this parliament has a
clear
democratic mandate to offer scotland
that choice
the uk government regrettably however is
refusing to respect scottish democracy
that is why today's statement is
necessary
the uk and scottish governments should
be sitting down together
responsibly agreeing a process including
a section 30 order that allows the
scottish people to decide
that would be the democratic way to
proceed it would be based on precedent
and it would put the legal basis of a
referendum beyond any doubt
that's why i am writing to the prime
minister today to inform him of the
content of this statement and in that
letter i will also make clear that i am
ready and willing to negotiate the terms
of a section 30 order with him
presiding officer
what i am not
willing to do
what i will never do is allow scottish
democracy to be a prisoner of boris
johnson or any prime minister
members
members there should be no interruptions
thank you
any interruptions thank you saying
officer the issue of independence cannot
be suppressed it must be resolved
democratically and that must be through
a process that is above reproach and
commands confidence
that is why i am setting out today the
actions the scottish government and the
lord advocate
will take in the absence of a section 30
order to secure scotland's right to
choose
my determination is to secure a process
that allows the people of scotland
whether yes no or yet to be decided to
express their views in a legal
constitutional referendum so that the
majority view can be established fairly
and democratic
the steps i am setting out today seek to
achieve that
they are grounded in and demonstrate
this government's respect for the
principles of rule of law and democracy
indeed these core principles respect for
the rule of law and respect for
democracy underpin everything i say
today
respect for the rule of law means that a
referendum must be lawful
that for me is a matter of principle but
it is also a matter of practical reality
an unlawful referendum would not be
deliverable even if it was it would lack
effect the outcome would not be
recognized by the international
community bluntly it would not lead to
scotland becoming independent presenting
officer it is axiomatic that a
referendum must be lawful
but my deliberations in recent times
have led me to this further conclusion
the lawfulness or otherwise of the
referendum must be established as a
matter of fact not just opinion
otherwise as we have seen again in
recent days opposition parties will just
keep casting doubt on the legitimacy of
the process so that they can avoid the
substantive debate on independence which
scotland deserves but they so clearly
fear
that is not in the country's best
interests
let me turn that into the detail of the
steps we will now take to secure that
objective of an indisputably lawful
referendum
and then ensure that from today we can
focus on the substance of why scotland
should be independent
planning officer i can announce first of
all that the scottish government is
today publishing the scottish
independence referendum bill
i will draw attention in particular to
three key provisions of this bill
firstly the purpose of the referendum i
set out in section one is to ascertain
the views of the people of scotland on
whether or not scotland should be an
independent country
in common with the 2014 referendum
indeed in common with the brexit
referendum and the referendum to
establish this parliament the
independence referendum proposed in the
bill will be consultative not
self-executing
just as in 2014 and recognized
explicitly in the 2013 white paper a
majority yes vote in this referendum
will not in and of itself make scotland
independent for scotland to become
independent following a yes vote
legislation would have to be passed by
the uk and scottish parliaments now
there has been much commentary in recent
days to the effect that a consultative
referendum would not have the same
status as the vote in 2014 that is
simply wrong factually and legally
let me be clear
the status of the referendum proposed in
this bill is exactly the same as the
referendums of 1997 2014 and 2016.
the next provision of the bill i wish to
draw attention to relates to the
question to be asked in the referendum
the bill states that the question on the
ballot paper should be
just as it was in 2014 should scotland
be an independent country
finally presiding officer the bill
includes the proposed date on which the
referendum should be held
in line with the government's clear
mandate this is a date within the first
half of this term of parliament
presiding officer i can announce that
the scottish government is proposing
that the independence referendum be held
on the 19th of october
2023
these are
thank you
thank you
members
these are the key elements of the
referendum legislation that the scottish
government wishes this parliament to
scrutinize and pass
let me turn now to the aim of
establishing as fact
the lawfulness of a referendum
which as i have remembered already
indicated i consider to be of the utmost
importance
i will start with what we know already
we know that the legislative competence
of the scottish parliament to pass this
bill in the absence of a section 30
order is contested we know that
legislative competence can only be
determined judicially
and we know that for as long as there is
no judicial determination opinions will
differ and doubt will continue to be
cast on the lawful basis for the
referendum that benefits only those
parties opposed to independence because
it allows them to avoid the substance of
the independence debate
finally we know that if this parliament
does seek to legislate without a section
30 order the bill will go to court that
is inevitable
the only questions are when it ends up
in court and at whose hand
if the issue of legislative competence
remains unresolved at the point of
formal introduction of a bill the uk
government will almost certainly use
section 33 of the scotland act to refer
it to the supreme court after it has
passed
it is also possible that one or more
private individuals will lodge a
judicial review of the bill indeed it
was reported last week that tory
supporters are already planning to do so
a challenge by private individuals could
also go through successive course and so
be a very lengthy process
either way at the point of parliament
passing the bill there would be no
certainty about when or even if it could
be implemented a court challenge would
still lie ahead and the timetable i have
set out today would quickly become
difficult to deliver
and of course between now and then claim
and counter claim
good faith arguments and bad faith
fear-mongering about so-called wild cat
referendums will continue to muddy the
water cast up doubt and taint the
process
deciding officer that may well suit
politicians opposed to independence but
none of it would be in the interest of
the country and none of it would serve
democracy
the fact is neither legal opinions nor
political arguments will resolve this
point we must establish legal fact that
is why in my view we must seek now to
accelerate to the point when we have
legal clarity legal fact and crucially
in doing so i hope establish and
safeguard the ability of this parliament
to deliver a referendum on the date
proposed
presiding officer it is to this end that
some weeks ago i asked the lord advocate
to consider exercising the power she has
under paragraph 34 of schedule 6 to the
scotland act to refer to the supreme
court the question of whether the
provisions in this bill relate to
reserve matters
this is a power exercisable by the lord
advocate alone not by scottish ministers
collectively whether or not she does so
is accordingly a matter solely for her
however i can confirm that the lord
advocate has considered this request she
has taken into account the following
factors
this government's democratic mandate
the constitutional significance of this
issue the fact that the bill does raise
a genuine issue of law that is
unresolved and the importance of
ensuring that this government and
parliament act lawfully at all times
she has now informed me of her decision
i can advise parliament that the lord
advocate has agreed to make a reference
of the provisions in the bill to the
supreme court
indeed presiding officer as i speak the
process for serving the requisite
paperwork on the uk government by
lawyers and messengers at arms is
underway and i can confirm that the
reference will be filed with the supreme
court this afternoon
signing officer
whether or not the reference is accepted
how long it takes to determine and what
judgment is arrived at and of course all
matters for the court to determine i
accept that
as i have made clear throughout this
government respects the rule of law
however by asking the lord advocate to
refer the matter to the court now
rather than wait for others to do so
later
we are seeking to deliver clarity and
legal certainty in a timely manner and
without the delay and continued doubt
that others would prefer
citing officer obviously it is this
government's hope that the question in
this bill proposing a referendum that is
consultative not self-executing and
which would seek to ascertain the views
of the scottish people for or against
independence will be deemed to be within
the legislative competence of this
parliament if that outcome is secured
there will be no doubt whatsoever that
the referendum is lawful and i can
confirm that the government will then
immediately introduce the bill and ask
parliament to pass it on a time scale
that allows the referendum to proceed on
the 19th of october next year
it is of course possible that the
supreme court will decide that the
scottish parliament does not have power
to legislate even for a consultative
referendum to be clear if that happens
it will be the fault of westminster
legislation not the court
members obviously
that would not be
the clarity we hope for
but if that is what the law establishing
this parliament really means
it is better to have that clarity sooner
rather than later
because what it will clarify presiding
officer is this any notion of the uk as
a voluntary union of nations is a
fiction any suggestion that the uk is a
partnership of equals is false instead
we will be confronted with this reality
no matter how scotland votes regardless
of what future we desire for our country
westminster can block and overrule
westminster will always have the final
say
presenting officer there will be few
stronger or more powerful arguments for
independence than that
and it would not be the end of the
matter far from it
i said earlier that two principles would
guide what i said today the rule of law
and democracy democracy demands that
people must have their say
so finally in terms of process let me
confirm this although it describes a
scenario that i hope does not arise
but if it does transpire that there is
no lawful way for this parliament to
give the people of scotland the choice
of independence in a referendum and if
the uk government continues to deny a
section 30 order my party will fight the
uk general election on this single
question should scotland be an
independent country
members
members
heading off
first minister if i meet members i do
think it's important regardless of the
content of any statement that we adhere
to parliamentary
standing orders and that we continue to
hear the statement without interruptions
thank you signing off to the path i've
laid out today is about bringing clarity
and certainty to this debate above all
it is about ensuring that scotland will
have its say on independence i want the
process set and trained today to lead to
a lawful constitutional referendum and
for that to take place on the 19th of
october
2023 that is what we are preparing for
but if the law says that is not possible
the general election will be a de facto
referendum
either way the people of scotland will
have their seat sending officer is the
lord advocate is now referring the
question of legality to the supreme
court that need no longer be the subject
of sterile political debate indeed the
subjudicity principle and our own
standing orders demand that the on
competence now be made in court and not
here in this chamber that means we can
and we should now focus on the substance
that is what this government intends to
do
in the weeks and months ahead we will
make the positive case for independence
we will do so with commitment confidence
and passion let the opposition if they
can make the case for continued
westminster rule and then let the people
decide
sending officer
to believe in scottish independence is
to believe in a better future it
involves an unashamedly optimistic view
of the world the belief that things can
be better than they are now
above all it means trusting the talents
and ingenuity of all of us who live here
no matter where we come from
it is not a claim to be better than
anyone else it is about looking around
at all the other successful independent
countries in the world so many of them
smaller than we are and without the
resources we are blessed with and asking
why not scotland think of all our
talents and advantages unrivaled energy
resources extraordinary natural heritage
exceptional strengths in the industries
of the future brilliant universities and
colleges a highly skilled and creative
population there is no reason at all
that an independent scotland would not
succeed
nothing in life is guaranteed but with
hard work and the independence to chart
our own course scotland will prosper and
the people of scotland have told us all
of us in this chamber that they want the
right to decide presenting officer today
we have set out the path to deliver it
thank you
thank you
the first minister will now take
questions on the issues raised in her
statement i intend to allow around 40
minutes for questions after which we'll
move on to the next item of business and
i'd be grateful if members who wish to
ask a question where to press their
request to speak buttons now and i call
him douglas ross thank you very much
presiding officer i wonder if that smp
applause was to make up for the people
in the public gallery actually walking
out as the first minister was speaking
because
nicola sturgeon
because nicola sturgeon is at it
all over again yeah her eye is off the
ball once more
the real priorities or people across
scotland are on the back burner
instead the first minister is putting
her plans to divide scotland front and
centre
nicholas sturgeon has shown again today
that the p's selfish obsession with
another divisive referendum is always
their top priority
she will use government time and
resources to further her plan to break
up the country just when we need to be
pulling together and working as one
all of our focus should be on tackling
the huge challenges we face right now
helping families with their bills
supporting frontline services and
creating good jobs
a potentially illegal referendum next
year is the wrong priority for scotland
members we will hear mr ross thank you
well
snp members
are unhappy about that it is being
referred to the court because the
legality of it is not known therefore it
is a potentially illegal referendum and
it would distract away from our recovery
it will damage our efforts to rebuild
the country after covet it is also the
last thing a clear majority of scottish
people want
the first minister speaks of fear
the first minister speaks of fear but
what concerns all of us is the price
scotland piece for her continued
obsession with another referendum so we
won't play nicola sturgeon's games we
won't take part in a pretend poll when
there is real work to be done
real work on the global cost of living
crisis real work to invest in public
services real work to rebuild our
economy
those are our priorities and they're the
real priorities of people across
scotland as well
but instead of focusing on the right
priorities nicholas sturgeon is
railroading this parliament into talking
about the smp's obsession
on the first minister's watch this is
becoming a do nothing parliament
nicholas sergeant has confirmed today
that she will introduce a bill for
another independence referendum
but what is she doing about the
country's top priorities
nothing
education no bills drugs no ideas
fairies none that float that is nicholas
sturgeon scotland and this parliament is
beginning to be a parliament that
doesn't get to act on the people's real
priorities a parliament that only exists
to further the snp's interests a do
nothing parliament with a first minister
obsessed with another referendum at all
costs
so can i ask the first minister
why should the people of scotland's real
priorities be put on the back burner for
another divisive damaging independence
referendum
first
minister well
i think the last count douglas ross had
three jobs he may be a do nothing msp
but this is certainly a do
much
parliament
[Applause]
an apparent inability to actually listen
to what we said
in the statement i know that the
legality of a referendum passed by this
parliament without a section 30 order is
contested that is why i have asked the
lord advocate to refer the matter to the
supreme court so that that can be put
beyond any doubt a referendum that goes
ahead will be indisputably illegal
because the supreme court will have
deemed it so
and at that stage any claims about
boycotts will sound even sillier than
they do now and demonstrate one thing
and one thing only the conservatives
have no confidence in the arguments for
the continuation of the union and now we
have a strange conundrum don't we in
scotland where the tories suggest that
nobody in scotland wants the opportunity
to choose independence in a referendum
and yet they have somehow managed to
elect a majority of msps in this
parliament who propose an independence
referendum douglas ross also says that a
clear majority don't want independence
can i gently suggest to him if he was
confident in that
he would be desperate to put the
question to the people of scotland in
a referendum
sending officer
my plans are to equip this parliament
and this country with all of the powers
and all of the resources other
independent countries take for granted
and that we need to navigate the
challenges that scotland in common with
the rest of the world face right now the
truth is scotland is paying a price for
not being independent ripped out of the
european union in the single market
completely against our will suffering at
one of the worst cost of living crises
in the developed world because of that
higher inflation than any other g7
country lower growth than any g20
country other than russia we're seeing
children pushed into poverty by a
conservative government that we didn't
elect scotland needs independent to
better navigate those challenges uh so
that all of the focus all of the power
all of the resources of this government
and future scottish governments can be
on exactly that addressing the
priorities of the scottish people in
line with mandates given by the scottish
people
[Applause]
it's important to establish the legal
basis of your referendum but it's also
important to consider the timing the
context and the effect
and i think the first ones that gave the
game away in the latter part of our
statement this is actually all about the
general election and the snp having some
relevance in it that actually about
discouraged people
but it's important to recognize the
context of the election campaign last
year
we were still a country living under
covered restrictions
over ten thousand of our fellow citizens
had lost their lives
nicola sargent said during that campaign
that people who didn't support a
referendum or independence through the
recovery should vote for her safe in the
knowledge that covert recovery would be
her priority
kovid hasn't gone away and our recovery
hasn't even started
since that election and when nicolas
sergeant gave that pledge
4 000 more scots have lost their lives
43
in the last week have died due to covet
there are over 700 000 scots on nhs
waiting lists over 10 000 children and
young people waiting for a mental health
appointment almost 20 000 fewer
businesses in scotland today than when
the pandemic began and this week the ons
warned that inflation could reach 11
meaning higher bills and the deepening
the cost of living crisis for households
across the country it doesn't feel like
the crisis is over
isn't it the case that the pandemic
nicola the search he wanted to pull us
through is gone and the partisan
nicholas sturgeon that wants to divide
our country is back pursuing a
referendum that two-thirds of scots
don't want right now worse still
isn't she using the thank you she was
given and the promise she made to lead
us through the recovery to instead put
scott against scott and focus on her
priority her obsession and her purpose
frankly scotland deserves better
first minister
democracy democracy is not pitting
anyone against anyone democracy is
allowing the people of the country all
of the people of the country to choose
that is not just the right way to
resolve differences of opinion on the
constitution that is the only way to
resolve these differences of opinion and
it doesn't surprise me
to hear the conservatives say
differently it does still surprise me to
hear labour set its face so firmly
against that fundamental concept of
democracy anna sarwar said it's all
about the context and the timing of a
referendum he may have more credibility
in saying that if his position wasn't
exactly the same as the tories which is
that scotland should never get the right
to choose independence in a referendum
and let me say the first minister
standing here is the first minister who
does and who always has believed that
the right thing for scotland to have the
powers the levers the resources in our
hands to chart our course
in line with our values our interests
and the aspirations ambitions we have
for the country and i don't want a
recovery in the mould of boris johnson
and the conservative party and we ana
salvador is right covet hasn't gone away
but i tell you what has happened a
westminster tory government that we
didn't vote for has taken the funding
for dealing with covid away from this
parliament we're seeing a chancellor
take money away from the poorest in our
society the way to build a recovery the
way to build the kind of country we want
the anna sarwar and i probably agree on
is to put the levers and the control of
that in the hands of the people of
scotland
that is what independence is about and
as long as anna sarwer and his party set
their face against that then i suspect
they will continue to struggle in the
way that they have over the last decade
and
more hamilton
thank you very much presiding officer
well here we are again and what's an
appalling waste well you have of course
been listening there to the first
minister of scotland nicolas sturgeon
laying out the reasons why she believes
that there should be a another
independence referendum held in scotland
she said that she has now advised the
lord advocate of scotland to go to the
supreme court to check on legality of
proceedings and also gave us a date when
this referendum may be held on the 19th
of october 2023 let's bring in dan
whitehead who is at hollywood forest and
has been listening to the first minutes
of their dan good to have you with us
again so
quite complicated but there is a process
here and it's going to first start i
think at the supreme court
yeah it's important to stress that the
scottish parliament doesn't have the
authority to hold a legally binding
referendum so what the first minister
has announced is that
she has announced a bill which has plans
for there to be a consultative
referendum on the 19th of october next
year the scottish government is already
referring that option to the supreme
court to check the legality of it if the
supreme court says no you can't even
have that consultative referendum
nicholas sturgeon says that will be the
fault of westminster's legislation but
clearly significant here that she is
looking to hold another referendum all
being consultative on the 19th of
october next year
appreciate that stan you you are
watching the sarah jamie show i am
kamali melbourne coming up
russia denies targeting a shopping
center in ukraine claiming it hit
weapons nearby as the prime minister and
the head of the army disagree on the
potential scale of the conflict
this is our 1937 moment
we're not at war
but we must act rapidly so that we
aren't drawn into one through a failure
to contain territorial expansion
i don't think it will come to that and
clearly we're working uh very hard to
make sure that we uh confine this to
to ukraine
our world leaders have condemned the
missile strike calling it a war crime
and promising to stand with ukraine for
as long as it takes
the number of people known to have died
inside a lorry in texas rises to 50
three people are in custody
doctors are calling for a 30 pay rise
over the next five years and threaten to
strike if their demands are not met
and there's applause from the snp as
nicholas sturgeon sets out her plans to
hold a another scottish independence
referendum
it comes as the queen joins armed forces
for a special parade
during hollywood week
[Music]
hello and good afternoon as russian
strikes on ukraine intensify with the
most recent on a shopping center killing
at least 18 people the head of the
british army has warned that while we in
the uk are not at war the country should
be prepared to react if necessary now
the prime minister was quick to try and
play down the words of general sir
patrick sanders and reassure the public
that there was no imminent threat to
britain
this is our 1937 moment
we're not at war
but we must act rapidly so that we
aren't drawn into one through a failure
to contain territorial expansion
so surely it's beholden